lahter with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and hopper
sixteen million dollars fifteen million
dollars fifty million dollars twelve
million dollars these are the salaries
of Jimmy Fallon Stephen Colbert Jimmy
Kimmel Conan O'Brien individually Trevor
Noah last I I read made about four
million in 2015
Trevor Noah currently has 22 writers
Jimmy Kimmel has 14 writers The Young
Turks received 20 million dollars in
2017 in funding and I say this to you
today to express the importance and the
gratitude we have for everyone in Mudd
Club listen we're in the same ballpark
as a lot of these shows because of you
the viewers and the listeners but just
as certainly we rely on you and Mudd
Club to continue growing this show we've
never received 20 million in funding
from a foreign caliphate we've run this
entire program budget on a small
fraction of their late-night host
salaries that includes all of our
salaries mine included advertising
production costs for hidden cameras
things all of it and up until this year
when ever had the luxury of 25 writers
we had one and now I'm fortunate enough
to have Brautigan helping along along
with their friend Penn tell us and
sometimes you're good for a known
benjamin part-time late-night has
ignored you but we hear you but because
laden with Grider is entirely
independent we can't do this show
without you we can't rely on social
media monetization and of course we
can't expect the big boys in media to
hear us so please join at ladders
credit.com /mo Club try for seven days
for you get The Daily Show this
wonderful hand etched mug and ensure
that the laughs the information and the
impact continues on a happy note through
your support of Mudd Club we just want
to let you know we are now hiring new
people as a part of our family here
grant someone who's worked with us here
for a while has had some personal health
issues he's not going to be here
full-time we love your grant and
hopefully he'll be coming back I know he
will be coming back with some freelance
work but we do have some full-time
positions available for a director slash
producer a videographer studio tech and
a production assistant slash associate
producer for in the field kind of
packages reporting hidden camera work
and eventually we'll be looking for a
showrunner senior producer so that I can
find some time to focus more on content
and my health but right now for the full
job descriptions go to a lot of worth
credit at comm slash jobs and because we
were very small lean team please
understand week
can't hire everybody we cannot respond
to everybody
our team is about the court of the size
of Trevor Noah's just writing staff so
we're gonna have to go through all of
these applications and if you're not a
fit with the experience just wait until
next time we will be hiring again so
again please join a lot of credit comm
/mo Club and apply at ladder with Crider
comm slash jobs good luck to everyone
enjoy the show
every day when you watch are you to be
every video that you see has been
demonetised just for you hey yourself
today or the censorship feel good and
this next word has to be it's a simple
message and it comes from the heart big
Ted can get some that would be a great
place to start and I say hey you to
converse for yourself today
on the censorships real game and this
next word has to be gaudi platform all
of these gaudi platform already JW
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know what I'm doing with this if
this were a John Woo film that would
have been in really slow mo and then
three hours long I don't know if this
time you still make films we have G
Morgan Jr with us what's one of the day
one of the day that could run much
because we have real black people here
according to 23andme the hodgetwins well
X I'm only fifty four percent black 54
percent black yeah darn and I assume you
are also fifty-four percent black unless
there's some of them with the mailman 53
with 53 pony oh you stole somebody's
have some shows coming up right yeah oh
yeah where you on we go to Detroit not
really dick Troy we're going to Royal
[Laughter]
Phoenix Arizona and Chicago yeah any
other channels at conservative twins
yeah you conservative for you and cause
I'm just been informed in my ear that's
been demagnetized we have on the show
today and we'll be talking about why
Trump will be reelected I really think
he's going to be reelected so there's
been the question of the day what would
you say the odds are of President Trump
being reelected do you think it depends
on his opponent who in the field I guess
do you see now or who could emerge in
the next two years do you think will
beYOU know I'm here you see your what
you think um we'll talk about that no
good news of course is the current
political drama in Virginia which now
includes the Attorney General and the
congressman all the while they're still
continued calls for governor Northam to
resign and I believe the governor if I'm
not mistaken is actually holding a press
conference to address the latest
controversy right now yeah we go to it
one question yet what do you see for
your resignation governor well you're
always going to have critics and all I
can say is that that definitely in the
pictures I've said on the record was not
a mission and I'd like to move on to
much more presentation okay guys you got
to stop with the gotcha journalism
here's what's dividing our country I
stand before you today an honest man and
totally focused on the man all right
guys listen you have to stop lobbing the
accusation of racism okay that's what
we're facing here in politics its
divisive and I'm telling you that I
don't care if you are black all right
no further questions almost seems like a
parrot on death so let's recap this
property your home state usually I think
people think West Virginia when they
think about things I'm good no yeah just
Virginia regular to recap we have what
the northern obviously black face photo
the Attorney General announced that she
too wore black face at a party once they
felt compelled to announce it apparently
serious allegations were there no of
rape against lieutenant governor in 2004
which were ignored by that by the way
from a Democratic congressman for over a
year we go now live to a recently called
emergency Virginia State Democrat
convention it's absolutely that's right
whoever is the next in the line of
succession like if these guys go out is
just sitting there waiting for the other
shoe to drop because there's what three
people in line right now in succession
so the governor lieutenant governor and
what was the other person you said the
80 or something like it somewhere is
Robert Byrd saying so you're saying but
it's great it's an absolute dumpster
fire I did not think of Virginia as this
racist of a place did you guys grew up
with us oh man it's late this leg these
that KKK parades through our city yeah
it's like once in the front yard you see
all these blackface mannequins no
statute yeah yeah
you're in your 30s no don't crack
especially when it's shoe polished on in
a more wholesome story a three-year-old
is everyone okay okay before the show we
weigh the exact same D really yeah but
they look much better a three-year-old
boy was lost in the woods and he
apparently hung out with a bear for two
days this comes from Sky News KC
Hathaway was found by search and rescue
teams in North Carolina after people
heard him calling for his mother the boy
claims that the bear helped him forge
for berries learn how to hibernate and
give him the inside skinny on nasa's
fake moon landing yeah so it seems as
though have called you a teat I know
that's not me back to oh my gosh the
show is going really well right now
we're turning to our I on India
[Music]
you guys been a lot of inia in there in
do you have hodge twins you guys been
there never bailed probably good that's
for you guys have you got a fan base for
Facebook New Delhi is chapter hit off
just one show and done
yeah it was the one Indian guy in Dallas
who so annoyed I am from India I love
you but he kept like ragging on you the
whole show no use giving you crap or was
he supporting you because I liked you
you are the one who looks like he knows
a bargain a lot one thing I'm not as
with Indian people is you agree in a
price and then they decide to negotiate
I don't know why that's true it's a
cultural thing
and I don't like it doesn't mean I don't
like Indians I just don't like that
component of the Indian people they got
a so an Indian man is suing his parents
true story because he didn't consent to
being born
Ralph Rafael Samuel is a so-called child
free advocate who believes children
shouldn't be made to suffer life and
thinks parents don't have the right to
give birth if a child has not agreed to
it well don't worry mr. Samuel governor
Northam has your back I think you two
are on the same page yes extending
abortion a little far late term if it's
they will have a discussion a mid-life
abortion really come on that's what's
gonna happen in Virginia no more midlife
crisis just melt midlife abortion
finally in another stroke before we get
to Donald Trump why he'll be reelected
the new emojis were announced on Tuesday
if you'll follow this by via the unicode
consortium is a thing an ink Linda they
were focusing mainly on accessibility
and
tation this is a quote from the next
batch features an array of inclusion
themed symbols like a woman and a man in
a wheelchair several new variations of
people holding hands and a period emoji
yeah that's a real that's an act that's
a real thing with a period emoji
apparently it needs to be celebrated
along with other your every other bodily
functional so every time I drop a deuce
now I'm going to send a text with a
picture and a smiley face actually in
exclusive we have some of the yet to be
released emojis from Apple which brings
us to this week seven plus one people
often forget the new machine every time
that's the new Walter that is made by
Walter Walter they were licensing it for
awhile now they're made in-house in
Arkansas they've been following the
emoji story let's have you read number 7
and 6 respectively the number 7 emoji we
have exclusive access to is what Keith
and or Kevin transgender it's ma'am yeah
that's the transgender mode number 6 is
the is the president Trump emoji is one
just so the hotsprings don't have to say
it is that this was not exactly
controversial not especially
controversial because it's the not
Mohammed emoji yeah very clear that is
not Mohammed no it's capitalized no it's
not because here's the actual Mohammed
emoji it's been around for a very long
time
[Laughter]
Abraham but there is no happier it's an
entire religion based on the Jews
[Laughter]
number four and a Modi's had to be
released people really proud of is the
pro-choice emoji is coming down the talk
okay really quick will skim along this
for the number three is a cancer emoji
that one makes sense actually number two
the Pocahontas emoji is one that
accurate yeah get your Texas bar and the
number one is the official emoji of the
state of Virginia this is Thomas yet to
be released
you forgot the chamber of course is this
salute emoji to Ruth Bader Ginsburg yeah
it seemed unfair this has been this week
every time German voices just make black
people we're gonna know sorry about
spiraling earlier kids I was my bad I
was okay it's calling another guy my
phone my buddy chowder I don't believe
that nice to Crowder yeah sure I think
he's kind of white guys the bear thing
going on over these it's like take a
night you know what no one really knows
by the way the winner I should say I
have this in front we have it written
down because mom said don't forget to
announce its winner of last week's
trivia contest is Katie Reynolds nice
thanks although eighty eight and so you
went oh that was the answer was about
Ralph Macchio yeah I don't really much
but you win a free t-shirt or Ranger
panties or item of your choosing and I
think an autographed picture a little
something from surprise honestly like
I'm saying guys if you enter the contest
will give you this stuff but I do
it's crap now when people start your
time for the Green Deal the green nudie
I didn't have time to read through all
of it before today's show
it does seem pretty insane and it does
leave me to the point that I do want to
discuss tonight
why I believe that President Trump is
going to be re-elected and the main
reason for this is that Democrats keep
giving him gifts they wondered like how
he won in the first place here that like
how did Donald Trump how could you
possibly won and how could
possibly when again I'll tell you
exactly how the left continues to give
this man gifts he really is there's like
a Chauncey Gardiner effect he's not
necessarily doing everything right
they're just doing everything wrong it
looks brilliant by comparison is already
looking for top you think he's gonna win
reelection oh yeah you guys that I hope
so you gonna vote for him oh hell yeah
oh here yeah do you vote for him the
first time yeah yeah last time I was get
caught up in those polls on CNN yeah
actually believe that's a lot that's a
lot of people though a lot of people who
didn't necessarily pull the lever for
Trump I think are more emboldened the
next time around
you guys said that you voted for Obama
at least the first time right first time
second time Mitt Romney
yeah oh wow oh that's surprising not for
me because he's like the whitest guy
ever dy he
yeah he's you tall white and that's
white yeah
there's white there's Larry Bird white
and then there's you Joe for some reason
library which is great at basketball so
he worth bellacor so I think do think at
the State of the Union which occurred
this week showcased exactly what I'm
talking with just how far left the DNC
has gone by the something that's
important note seventy / 70 is at 76 76
76 percent of Americans approved of the
speech what's really bad for Democrats
is that 81 percent of independents
approved the speech I think we have all
relations come from from YouGov and the
more that the left continues to push
their their agenda toward the left the
Democrats I should say pushing their
agenda toward left the more likely to
these independent voters who everyone
said Trump it just has this ceiling
right he has this ceiling and it's his
base well the truth is his base actually
the little people are the biggest
problems with President Trump we'll get
into those in a second it seemed that
the independence actually the people in
the middle are really starting to thaw
on the guy yeah absolutely they're
starting to come around in huge numbers
I've never seen numbers like that for
independence that's the coveted group of
people that everybody goes after in
elections they try to rile their base up
and right try to get independence when
that high of a percentage of
independents agree with your State of
the Union that was never supposed
happen in the first place yeah you're
right doing something really wrong on
the other side really wrong agree on
anything no they're independent for a
reason they should independent should
just read difficult
yes very definitive yeah and he had
eighty-one percent of them to support
the reality show got yeah like think
about this for a second how badly must
you screw up that the guy who is
literally trademark you're fired
yes beating the crap out of you the
second lowest polling politician in US
history to run for president and you
picked the person below him let's go
through kind of four examples I think
this is one that's really important late
term abortion so here's a clip where
President Trump called for legislation
to end the late term abortions and he
mentions Northam discussion of killing
babies after birth this is an important
clip for people to see there you go now
to defend the dignity of every person I
am asking Congress to pass legislation
to prohibit the late term abortion of
children
[Applause]
certain people who refuse to stand at
that think about this first thing you're
an independent washings going let's at
least agree to stop babies that could
feel pain being ripped apart no okay
right good no you're gonna sit on your
hands for God do you have any idea how
the optics look in here something that's
really important I think maybe you guys
are necessarily cuz you weren't really
political junkies in the last election
and I know you'll vote in the next
election but Trump by the way was
pro-choice yeah up until he ran as a
Republican effectively and conservatives
were really really leery of it because
of that right yeah we never think he was
conservative they didn't think he was
conservative and so Donald Trump found
himself in a pickle in the primaries
particularly because he had to appeal to
his base the conservatives he had to
prove to them that he was pro-gun that
he was pro-life while still appeasing
moderates and that's hard to do when
they think that you can't win over
either of them now again the Democrats
have given him a gift and that he can do
a you can now appeal to his pro-life
base and even the moderates who just
don't want to see babies being born
alive kill all he has to say is hey hey
a forty week old baby big chapter the
headband think about that for a second
yeah all the Democrats had to do was say
hey most Americans are relatively
pro-choice because it's a term that we
created to trick them and some of them
are stupid so let's go with that and
instead they said forty week abortions
right forty weeks and Donald Trump was
I'd call your bluff
well I mean all you had to do is not
kill babies once they were born I mean
if you had drawn the line a little bit
further back and just not gone that far
a lot of this may not have come up right
but the minute that you start saying
stuff like the Virginia Governor said
and then you pass bills in New York and
then trance s what she says
you've just riled up an entire base of
voters you did not want this to be the
issue no exactly and it didn't stop why
would you have to kill the forty or
forty week you do exactly baby Wow
because you don't want it yeah and you
know what's crazy my uh my daughter was
born premature she was eight months
eight months yeah I think months I'm not
entirely sure I think the viability
after twenty five weeks is over fifty
percent now well after twenty weeks it's
still viable the percentage goes down
but it's still possible for somebody
weeks
ability or is it's like the left is on
an island and it's shrinking it's kind
of like the island that Al Gore
described only it's Carroll the Florida
Court described early never happen said
that the tide is just rising they have
less and less land because babies are
becoming more viable as technology
progresses so they have less and less of
an argument well in it and this is a
very horrible thing to happen right you
don't want a bill coming in New York
like this that allows this for any
period of time but I think it's also it
happens to have a huge silver lining
because it's one of the best things it's
waking people up around the country to
the horrors of abortion who may have
just kind of swept it under the rug as a
woman's right to choose and kind of
bought that line now they have to deal
with the reality of post-birth if it's a
botched abortion or abortion right up
until delivery any that's now talking
about the beauty of it is and I don't
mean the beauty of it but this situation
is people see 40 weeks they go hannes i
can4t that's really extreme where am i
okay with abortion right and they go
back in 125 week that's in a lot of
states what 25 weeks yeah right and they
are dumbfounded a lot of people think
it's Plan B they think it's some woman
who's going in there was some incest or
rape that occurred which is a very very
small minority of cases and instead
they're going to wait people are killing
these babies at 25 weeks old and this is
legal and now they're pushing for it to
be legal with this broad health
exception everywhere else all it
requires is anyone who is against the
killing of a 30 40 25 week old baby now
Donald Trump has won on the issue of
abortion
congratulations Democrats no Republican
has won public appeal on the issue of
abortion in probably two decades because
a cool man had a larger voice he would
be an office Ben Carson's house for sale
no it was in Florida or Vegas dudes a
pool gold little angels by the bathtub
was like a Russian bath house it's a man
Carson's bath yeah if he's letting his
money do the talking for him because he
can't I like to see
so the placing of the mirrors it was
opposite the toilet like he wants to
watch his paper like I have no idea so
another example where the left is lost
all around is a pushing for open borders
so in the state of the union Trump
mentioned ice rescuing women and
children from sex traffickers watch what
I think Acacio Nina Pinta Santa Maria
coroner's des refuses to clap for for
this here's the clip more than 1500
sadistic traffickers have been put
behind bars
[Applause]
on the left
stone-cold [ __ ]
[ __ ] I out get out
I'll get up for the first Sabbath sex
slavery I don't like him but I'll do
that like this you just handed him a
gift by the way they were wearing white
[Laughter]
gosh up Cortez who are you wearing I'm
wearing white for women's rights except
all the underage hookers against their
will oh I cannot believe it what rights
do women don't have the men do it well
wearing white after Labor Day I'm not
sure and here's the thing not even
talking about the sex trafficking okay
that's one that again if you just work
you have to play the game in politics
everyone knows this a little bit we
don't like it but when someone says
ending sex trafficking even if you go
home second I know that Cortez when
she's talking about and in sex
trafficking it's actually attached to
the green New Deal pill and that's
actually about seventy percent tax so I
don't like it but she did say in sex
trafficking all right later they didn't
clap at that but if you go even further
in the issue a new CBS poll shows that
72% of Americans agreed with Trump
specifically on immigration anyway
here's I'm saying it it's just in from
our CBS News instant poll here following
the president's State of the Union 76
percent of speech watchers said they
approved of what they heard I'm very
surprised a large percentage err I'm
very surprised that any of these
percentages are true that's why I had to
play that clip well you would believe
that I'm not just saying it when she's
been portrayed as like this strong
independent Latina woman and that's why
we hate her and when that happened she's
like hey um guys do we do we clap at
this clip I'm not really sure hold on
we'll stand up but not not clap okay yet
I'm independent
and I do my own thing by the way the
funniest thing I thought Trump was
making a comment he said one in three of
these women that are being brought
across the border are actually raped or
sexually assaulted in the process of
coming across the border and one of the
the fact-checking organization says well
that's partially true it's actually 31%
you just lost the fourth country's guys
come on here's this here let me
just paint a picture free just a moment
here okay I'm trying to actually wrap my
head round hard to do it's like when
they fat check Donald Trump that where
he said we we had burgers stacked a mile
high at the way I'm sure like actually
they were placed in more of a horizontal
spread one couldn't account for the
vertical metrics because of the buttons
and depending on the temperature of the
room for a second okay the guy who said
you could do whatever you grabbed by the
B and disgusted a whole nation now has
the moral high ground because you've
decided to vilify him because he's
against sex trafficking and he had the
number off by two percent yes you
couldn't possibly make it easier for me
now everyone forgets about the grab by
the Eagle actually that 33 percent of
people who are raped when they try to
get here against their will it's 31
percent you better get in line
presidential but I'll he need to say
you're at peace and they're like you
know what I kind of am yeah got this
door here I should almost be
prioritizing the women who are being
raped there are calling snowflakes for
nothing
thank you not that guy looked like a
snowflake with a toupee on by the way
hit the notification bell if you're
subscribed on YouTube because pay
earlier subscriptions when I show up in
your box join mukil if you want the show
every single day a lot of credit
accomplishment clip and a subscribe rate
us on iTunes here's the second example
for we get to the prime example the left
of course is pushing socialism this is
another reason I think President Trump
is going to to win their outright
pushing everyone used to veiled yeah
releases like what when people said we
think that Barack Obama is kind of a
socialist right yeah socialism is
actually it's a dog whistle which it's
the inward think he's a socialist by the
way there are people and there are
people like in Norway who are socialist
to they're not black at all actually
like really white like really strong for
some reason we have no idea as to why
yet we're still running some genetic
testing but we actually think that
Barack Obama is like a Norwegian
socialist that's it no Trump just said
that we're never going to be
let's country and look at who refuses to
applaud here you go
socialism in our country America was
founded on liberty and independence and
not government coercion domination and
control we are born free
[Applause]
[Laughter]
poorly my afternoon my number to zoom in
close-ups in the history of presidential
speeches had sex with a crazier older
grumpy cat he set up he's like an camera
to go he greased the palms of one camera
guy the network's they don't like him
because hey listen camera operator
number four you know what
and Acacio Nina Pinta Santa Maria Cortez
these are the starters their actual
social she actually thinks that she's
going to pass some kind of seventy
percent tax I explained it somehow the
notion of socialism to that particular
regime are you what do you think about
the president why he did that well I
think I think that he needs to do it
because he feels like he feels himself
losing on the issues American public has
been overwhelmingly popular even some
with a majority of Republican voters
supporting supporting of what we're
talking about when we talked about a
seventy percent marginal tax rate on
incomes over ten million dollars sixty
percent of Americans approve it a
majority of Republicans support
socialism what I thought this was well
known heyyou person next to me is this
well it's not well known I don't know
what I'm saying Christmas she probably
with the wassail something let's be
honest here oh my gosh do we have to act
like that sounds like an intelligent
woman no let's to pretend you just think
Nancy Pelosi doesn't sound like an idiot
i I think she's wrong I think she's the
only person in politics who's
proactively evil but she just sounded
like an idiot
doesn't sound like an idiot no this girl
sounds like a [ __ ] look at Trump says a
lot of dumb stuff and I think they went
out and found the only person on the
left that could possibly sound dumber
and elected her to Congress as a 29 year
old bartender with no experience doing
anything right yes why is it buffalo
wings of its chicken people still don't
want to attack some stuff with the prank
calls this week where we call black
businesses yeah would it make you more
or less like a new support governor of
the MIDI supports increased taxes this
could be like a spoof like Donald Trump
at some point wrote a playbook that said
oh if they're gonna beat me here all the
things that you can do to beat me he's
like laughing with his cronies behind
the scenes it's like they've picked the
absolute worst ideas possible to win an
election and they've done all of them in
the Tuileries it's like guys listen I
think Donald Trump is bright enough but
I don't I don't think he's as brilliant
as obviously his diehard supporters do I
think sometimes he's just been given
these gifts like I think this is the
equivalent to reverse psychology
actually working
Hey hey Cortez Hey the one Pig you got
the what dig okay the only thing that
you know I told way to remove his frame
cut his hair once you get exactly what I
told her the first two times how do you
not put it together strong and dumbs
John Samson I think the greatest example
of course of the gifts that the left has
been they've been giving Donald Trump
and I hope they do it again in 2020 is
um they ran Hillary Clinton in a general
election yeah likely the one person
Trump was capable of eating at that time
truck pulled very badly for people who
forgot this leading up to the election
almost every single pollster got it
wrong because he was pulling so badly
and he's been receiving nothing but
hostile media coverage since here's the
thing the choice in 2020 is very
different from 2016 you are not a trump
though and I was not a Trump guy in the
primaries now we argued about it we
argued about it because I remember
saying well listen if he does win you
know he's gonna be the guy at that point
but it wasn't my guy like Carly Fiorina
I like Ted Cruz yeah and I pretty much
liked everyone not named who is it
well yeah Jeb Bush obviously or John
Kasich Jeb Bush I was like no way and
John Kasich just because that coming
that guy's just a weiner nothing
personal I just see him and I go you
ever see someone who makes just go who's
a guy from Ohio I guess ya know how
about little Marco do you like little
Marco I did my little Marco but John
Kasich has that haircut where he looks
like a like he looks like a bird caught
in an oil spill I mean I'm talking about
after BP the Crisco was in the water no
John Kasich we got some john Kasich's
here Washington we got some jag cases
and we're washing them off with Dawn so
the choice though in 2023 w in 2016 2016
a lot of people thought that both
Hillary and Trump were kind of taking us
toward a cliff I think ben shapiro
summarized it as though the concerns of
many by the way he said the fear was
that if Trump got in the office and he
did a bad job
it'd be like we're heading toward the
cliff just as we'd be heading toward the
cliff with Hillary Clinton but with
Donald Trump there would be no break
right because no Republican would be
elected after Donald Trump if he did as
bad of a job that many people
anticipated myself included in the
primaries I remember saying like I do I
think we deserve to lose if we run him
in the primary yeah of course when he
was against Hillary Clinton I mean
listen come on you just take the free
shots when you're giving them people
thought Hillary Clinton that was
ultimately a politician right that's
what people didn't like her they thought
she's a politician but his leftist go
relatively moderate you know the thing
with Hillary Clinton aside is she wasn't
super fun she wasn't there was Bernie
Sanders and Hillary Clinton yeah Trump
on the other hand people also thought a
lot of people think because he says bad
words that he's somehow extremely he was
actually seen as really
pretty moderate and not that
conservative so a lot of conservatives
weren't big fans of Trump as a matter of
fact I think you'll be surprised when
you look at those voting blocs
evangelicals voted for Trump because
they had to but not all of them probably
likely fewer in a lot of municipalities
but you saw a lot of Union voters would
have typically gone Democrat the Blue
Dogs go for Donald Trump so a lot of
those people held their nose as though
the Evangel the Christians the true
conservatives and voted for Trump
because Hillary Clinton was such an
insufferable
that's really why but now in 2020 were
choosing between Donald Trump who's been
really pretty conservative if you look
at him as a president outside of the the
trade issues is pretty good and all
Democrats who swung so far to the left
they're right nut hasn't seen them in a
month we know they want abortion up to
40 weeks 70 % tax rates as you just saw
completely socialized health care they
want to destroy our economy on principle
versus Donald Trump who is done well by
nearly all metrics available to us at
this point besides tweeting mean words
some of which are misspelled let's be
honest outside of that he's done pretty
well the choice in 2020 when they say
it's stark there well we think there's a
stark contrast to the Democrats and
Donald Trump it is but in a positive way
for Trump because these gifts that the
Democrats keep giving them so when
Republicans say that we need to be more
moderates this is something people have
to like hey listen we need a more
moderate Republican Party we need to
come to the middle I gohan a second
look how far the left is going don't
stare a gift horse in the mouth we're
gonna be back here with Gavin McGinnis
after this
hi I'm Betty hi and mug Club allows me
to be a stay-at-home dog so I can do all
the things I'm most passionate about
like fightin pots let me hear you bunk
wait till I get a holier you'll rue the
day you ever heard the name Betty
Crowder
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
don't be a victim
try the Walther you'll be glad you did I
don't want just nobody that's that I
think that's Uncle Phil in that song
really happy to have our next guest on
long time friend of the show a lot of
people have been asking for him to be on
the show I was said of speaking with him
not necessarily on the show and he will
be here live in studio for several days
next week not as a guest but as third
share is an active contributor here a
lot of care you can follow right now go
and support Ahmet defend Gavin Hakam I
guess a recently unemployed talk show
host but comedian extraordinaire Gavin
McGuinness how are you sir I'm pretty
good how are you doing I'm doing I'm
doing okay thank you this is a more
casual Gavin than we're used to seeing I
don't think I've ever seen you in a
white t-shirt you usually did the
falling down outfit yeah my life has
been destroyed so I'm emptying my bank
account on this lawsuit I'm unemployed I
don't really have anything going on
thanks to the SPLC so okay there's a lot
to unpack there and I want you to take
the initiative because I don't want to
go anywhere that we're not supposed to
the SPLC you're suing them correct
that's defend Gavin calm tell me what's
going on with that exactly
well they set their sights on me around
when Trump won and the proud boys and I
think their beef is well I think the way
the SPLC works is they realized that
calling everyone a Nazi makes for good
money because they scare him into
thinking that America you look at their
hate map and it's just it looks like
someone barf thumbtacks on to UM pack
blue we have an actual physical brochure
that they handed out at a train station
I didn't know that they actually and I
didn't believe the map until I looked it
up online to corroborate it's 100% true
oh the criteria to be on this map is
stunning I mean if there is one woman
Jennifer Morris who she's for man woman
adoption before gay adoption yeah that
means she wants all homosexuals to die
and will kill them tomorrow yeah in
their book and
churches by the way some of them are
actually just churches but yeah go ahead
conservatives they have a blind spot for
jihad which I don't quite get the only
time you see Muslims on their list is
ayaan Hirsi Ali for saying I'm kind of
over my religion after they cut off my
clitoris and yeah and might seed Nawaz
who went from radical extremists to
moderate and so they called him an anti
Muslim extremist for which he sued them
in one it would seem like one would kind
of leave the faith when you lose your
clitoris as you put it it would seem as
though the Southern Poverty Law Center
should be more concerned with poor
people who don't have clitoris --iz yeah
it's really odd to give Islam a pass
especially when your whole thing is
Nazis and anti-semitism if you're
looking for anti-semitism wear a
yarmulke around Paris wear a yarmulke in
a predominantly Muslim neighborhood and
see how many high-fives you get you'll
get a lot more than walking through the
Catskills or Alabama for them I've
talked about this before I think that if
you look at modern is it countries that
have Islamic rule not every Muslim in
the United States okay lift the preface
it with that but any country that has
Islamic rule it would certainly be more
comparable to the worldview to the
ideology the philosophy of Nazism than
free enterprise the Liberty we've seen
the United Sates it would be something
that could not be argued with yet they
want to label places here Nazis and give
it a pass I've really made in a very
literal sense if you look at Islam if
you look at Islamic Islamic Lee run
countries they don't like the Jews they
want to see them completely eviscerated
for the map yeah well they'll carry
scientists say I love Hitler at these
and Muslim rallies they the protocols of
Zion does very well in the Middle East
it's it's pretty strange and you look at
their definition of extremism and Nazi
and with proud boys they would say white
nationalist all the time and I would get
lawyer letters and send it's not just
the SPLC but to media so many it goes
okay okay I don't to get sued far right
and you go far right I mean I'm I'm
against the drug war I'm Pro gay I'm
pro-israel how am I
r-right but to them and when I say them
I mean the left these days here in clown
world if you're not 100% with us
you're 100% against us right so the
people that end up on this Nazi list
like what the SPLC the extremists
include Penn Carson Laura Ingraham
Jeanine Pirro
I it would definitely include a 2004
Bill Clinton who was against gay
marriage yeah or an Obama or a Hillary
from back then who was president who
could not be included for his stance on
gay marriage upon entering office would
be Donald Trump no but but you are
correct and it really is it's terrifying
especially when you consider that the
SPLC is one of the main I don't I guess
you would say one of the main seats and
those this board of directors that
YouTube has in determining content
guidelines a lot of people don't know
that the SPLC are used as a reference as
a guide for YouTube when determining
what should be flagged what should be
considered hate speech that's what I
want to get into in Discovery I want to
get into exactly who they're influencing
who they're telling it's it's sort of a
form of extortion like Al Sharpton does
where he goes into an organization and
says either let me be in control of who
does what or I'm gonna call you racist
and you'll be in big trouble so they and
they just keep it crewing more power and
more money money and power the same
thing and they keep accruing all this
money and power until they control
social media and you know in an age when
newspapers are dying controlling social
media is controlling the national
discussion right so in a way they're
kind of trying to take over America they
want to be judge jury and executioner
and decide who gets a job who can do
business like Jennifer Morris getting a
call from her bank and at the same time
their judgment system seems to be
totally random
I call it Becky like a mean girl in high
school they had a headline that I talked
about my press conference where they go
you want baguettes Gavin this is how you
get bigots and you're like you're you're
taking over the Magna Carta you're that
you're the new judicial system and you
talk like that what a strange
combination I thought you were doing
your Alexandria in a Pinta Santa Mira
Cortes impression right there I was I
was tricked for a second she the green
new deal getting guarantee jobs what how
do you Baron T jobs yeah she
she said I every time I listen to her I
just sounds like it one of those
annoying college students who was kind
of hot and she didn't like that she was
hot cuz she wanted more substance so she
shaved her head and started talking
about politics but you can still see
that she's a nine right and she's like
oh I'm not a pretty girl I'm like a
revolutionary yeah and then she like on
Trump State of the Union she said I just
thought it was really morose and you're
like yeah I understand if you don't like
Trump but morose morose I think she
thinks the word morose means moronic
yeah you know it's funny that you
mentioned that I thought at first let me
give her the benefit of doubt maybe it's
when he was referring to your abortion
policies there aoc but I don't think I
think I was lost on her well she just
morose and it's like what are you
getting emo Canada Senses Fail concert
no I think you're right she wants to be
more substantive a look at my beret but
you get a couple Smirnoff ices in her
and she's dancing on the rooftop as
we've seen this is also a its defend
Gavin calm I want to get into your suit
specifically but essentially that you
mentioned you know they want to control
social media Jack Dorsey was just on Joe
Rogan show recently and I was surprised
obviously a veteran Joe Rogan show he's
been on this show consider him a friend
of the show surprised how soft that
interview was Jack Dorsey evaded a lot
compared to how your interview went on
Joe Rogan or or my interview went and he
was talking for example about brexit and
he said you know we've realized there's
there's a problem on I think we'll do a
rebuttal for this next week because it's
a three-hour show and a lot of people
didn't really get to see what was going
on there but objected one point Jack
Dorsey said for example brexit I
realized that Twitter was really
amplifying all these reasons to leave
and if you were on Twitter all you would
see are reasons to leave and there
wasn't really a discussion about reasons
to stay and I was saying well a second
that's because it's on every single
mainstream news outlet the the scales
are a little bit tipped because people
who have never been allowed a voice
before for example with this show
compared to ABC NBC CBS comedy central
there's one alternative the same thing
happens with brexit and he it was lost
on him and Joe didn't follow up on that
so I wonder if you had watch that
interview at all or what your opinions
are on Jack Dorsey I was on Infowars
yesterday I think it was and Alex Jones
was going off about Joe Rogan saying
that Joe was is taking money from
Twitter and he's not telling anyone
about it
and I want to be on Joe Rogan really bad
to help raise money for this case so I I
was like oh I don't know he's not so bad
anything about that I don't know how one
would get money I mean I will say this
we get money from YouTube when the
videos aren't demonetised so I think
it's somewhere between 30 and 40 percent
of our videos so we got that big YouTube
money you know we're honest about it
yeah I've been Deamonte SPLC got media
monetized I can't do Google Adsense so
all my videos are free I encourage
people to rip off my YouTube content
because I know I'm gonna be shut down
any second now but I'm glad what you
said something really interesting about
how the the left thinks that social
media got you know Trump elected or
brexit to happen ya know Dorsey
specifically people got that to happen
you we're all trying to leave citi field
after a Mets game and you've closed off
all the doors you closed off mainstream
media you closed off all these different
avenues and the only door that was open
was social media so yeah we all came out
that door that's not the doors fault
it's our only option you know when Trump
held up his phone
in Florida and went like that and we saw
80,000 people in the stands we went holy
crap we're being lied to this guy's
really popular right if he hadn't done
that we wouldn't have known that's not
Twitter's fault right and he'll who
couldn't held up her blackberry at the
high school basketball court and it was
about too bad I don't know too about
center court and she said look and we
said wow this seems about right we think
that New York Times 99% projection seems
a little bit generous at this point so
why have they mentioned the Southern
Poverty Law Center having targeted you
specifically how so because they've
targeted a lot of conservatives but what
do you mean and how are you going about
this legally for people who don't know
again its defend gavankar we find the
complaint online and it is very involved
it's incredibly well-written was Ron
Coleman a free speech lawyer who went to
the Supreme Court with the band the
slants because they were saying wouldn't
couldn't trademark their name right and
he won that case it's incredibly well
written but they I know that it that
they targeted me because you look at the
articles and it came out of nowhere and
then it was just boom boom boom boom
boom post after post after post after
post and the media is so mentally
obese they're so in curious and lazy
that every single time they mentioned me
are the proud boys they'd mentioned
labeled as an extremist labeled as a
hate group and it just becomes fact it's
funny because curious guys like you and
I who are in the fray we wrote off the
SPLC a long time ago right we like you
laugh at them the ADL the Washington
Post CNN they they had credibility even
the New York Times is hanging by a
thread right but then you talk to other
people who don't aren't news junkies and
they go oh my god the SPLC they know
what they're talking about man that's
the Southern Poverty Law Center they're
experts they have no in the name it they
help the Southern Poverty raishin is
helping with the poverty and they're
fighting the hate hates everywhere hates
on the rise rights empowered an age of
Trump
it was always lying there looming in the
shadows and then Trump got out after
charlottesville Trump got on the mic and
said okay hope you can come out now and
there was it was like the day after day
oh you know the Sun seemed really bright
you know you do coke all night in a bar
and you find the owner lets you out at
9:00 a.m. when you're like wow it's
really bright out here I also don't know
it sounded like the the person calling a
a Jack Dempsey fight ok hate you're
gonna come out now Rampal that's what it
that's where they are they're in the 20s
in fact I was just reading about Jack
Dempsey we talked to him before yeah but
there was a fight with this guy what the
hell no Sarah no no it was a black guy I
think his name was Willis or wills and
promoters didn't want to take the fight
because they knew it would be Jack
Dempsey versus the black guy and be seen
as a racial thing black/white and then
everyone talked about race all the time
and so even back then they were like uh
I don't want to get into the racial
thing I don't to be called racist it's
boring and let's just fight a different
guy right because the social justice
warriors of the 20s will take this fight
into identity politics use the drinking
fountains but I just don't want to get
into it you know publicly right now I
mean let's speak the drinking fountains
let's just drop it okay
yeah that's really Trump is like they
think when he says make America great
again he wants
you're a bum Charlie this is that this
is the New York I want back the one
while you're Kent the Negroes aren't
playing baseball
no amplifier for you you going to the
end of it to a papaya I didn't even then
if there's some you'll be lucky to have
it yeah I know it really is something I
think the reason they want to say that
is because a significant percentage of
people who voted for Barack Obama voted
for Trump you can see that what the
hodgetwins who are here today just the
numbers don't add up and so they have to
say well really people voted for Barack
Obama but that that hate was lurking
beneath the surface to try and discount
the fact that a lot of people were
willing to overlook some shortcomings to
have the first black president I think
that's a component to it that's just
opinion but they've been gone after you
for a long time and like I said the
proof that it's concerted that's what
always bothers me like Alex Jones I
agree with Alex Jones on very little and
I think sometimes he's gone too far and
I've talked about that he's been on this
show and I've been on his show but there
is no denying that the deep platforming
occurred immediately in quick succession
you can't say that that's a coincidence
at that point no no the reason that
they're out to get me is because I'm
effective the reason they are out to get
the proud voice is because it's a
popular movement and in both cases they
are red pilling young people and getting
them on the Trump train and that's their
worst nightmare
so they knowingly lie I don't believe
the left sinks that the people they call
Nazis are Nazis in fact did I ever tell
you this story at my NYU talk I came out
after I'd been pepper sprayed for being
a Nazi I remember that I came I grabbed
a mic and I said we got three problems
with this country the Negro the woman
and the Jew and everyone just went
including all the protesters their jaws
hit the floor and then of course I said
just kidding just kidding I'm not that
guy but why did your jaws drop because
you pepper sprayed me because you
thought it was that guy but then I start
talking like that guy and you all have a
heart attack so I don't believe that you
believe that everyone's you know these
evil bigots like what the Catholic
school kids did they really think that
there was this beautiful indigenous
ceremony uh-uh-uh
and these maggot kids go this is gay
just
[Laughter]
it's actually a funeral we're having a
funeral here in this teepee yeah smash
was the peace-pipe
I mean I think that's what goes on I you
know I and do we really think that
Africa what's his name Phil Russy what's
Noah's Phil with him but was the the the
Native American I keep forgetting his
name - Phil Oh Nathan do it did anyone
actually think I think it was a the guy
from a national room I think was Bill
Kristol I could be wrong but someone
like that said you know he's an example
of what America can be alone do we
really think this guy's a wise sage like
even if you think those kids are douchey
because it's a trucker hat and no let's
go with that fine do we really think
that this guy is any kind of example of
how to act as a grown adult in any
capacity do we have to pretend that he
was a refrigerator technician for the
military when Abel was incompetent and
terrible at fixing refrigerators not
exactly the hero that we he's not the
hero we need is the hero we want I don't
understand was in Halifax where they
were accused of disrupting indigenous
ceremony and it was just a screw Canada
rally on Canada Day and the the one
leading it was an equally bad
representation of Indians and she called
herself chief grizzly mama and then the
head of Canada's Foreign Affairs goes I
would like to apologize to chief grizzly
mama
we're so it's like dude google it
there's no Indian chief called chief
grizzly mama
and why would make a chief I would tell
across what's happening here they were
pantheistic society that's where they
didn't use the wheel they just said hey
why is the why does water exist because
the gods say water exists and why is the
sky blue because the gods of the sky
make it well it took a Christian to come
over ago actually we've been encouraged
to examine our surroundings and create
critical theory not a big fan of the
Native American culture in case you
can't tell so what are you doing a big
you are oh that's right sorry I'm sorry
your wife yeah yeah I mean I love Native
so much I made three
yeah but she's not hitting that hit
hitting a snare drum made of will skin I
imagine she seems pretty pretty
Americanized / Canadian iced sure sure
but they all still go to powwow and I'll
do all that stuff fancy dancers and
funerals and with the peyote and the TP
and sweat lodges Jesus you've got a
sweat lodge it is brutal anyway we're
getting off topic here sweat lodge that
was that there was a cult thing where
some white guy tried to do it and then a
bunch of people died because he didn't
he didn't leave the vent hole it's like
the teepee that's my fear when I'm in it
I'm like you guys aren't doctors how do
you know that this is a reasonable
amount of heat because it feels a little
excessive how do you know why we're not
literally baking in here yeah can we get
a doctor who our temperatures yeah they
have no idea okay so defend Gavin calm
what is it that you are specific are you
filing for information exactly this is a
petition for information are you
actually at the suing stash
I think it's called tortious
interference I'm not that well versed in
in legality but yeah the the big picture
is I'm doing it for everyone else I'm
doing it for like take I on here see
ally right she dares to point out things
about radical Islam
she doesn't movie with with that Vance
Theo van Gogh he gets murdered because
of the movie and the SPLC pushes this
anti Muslim extremist so she needs
round-the-clock security which is real
expensive I think it's about two grand a
day so we got six hundred grand a year I
don't know if she has to pay that but
whatever she has to pay it's it's it's a
lot of money and it's because of labels
like this I mean they make this fake
America that's full of bigots because it
pays money but then these bigots that
they stick the label on have to suffer
and have their lives ruined right and
it's it's it's wrong and it's a terrible
depiction of America like this whole
hate has no home here this whole auntie
fav you of the world can you imagine
just walking through life sinking ever
fifty percent of the country or Klansmen
that's a racist that's a racist that's
an anti-semite
that's a homophobe but you've never met
one but you hear they're everywhere yeah
if you live in Virginia there's a solid
chance you can point in any direction
and there's a Klansmen and or blackface
and he's running your your state but
it's just that's the one place it's
Virginia
you're gonna clean blackface and or KKK
I don't even know which one is more
offensive no I think I think it's a very
important point that not everyone has
the kind of platformers has had the kind
of reach that you do and it's important
we talk about this with Charles Hermes
in UTA with the students there who are
who are suffering the students who are
silenced by professors who fail them you
know it's it's someone has to do
something a lot of people say someone
has to do something you're doing
something and you're gonna be doing more
here next week here in third chair
taking an active role here in the show
it's defend Gavin dot-com and you know
one thing I will say - I know a lot of
conservatives this is something that I
see a lot of conservatives don't all
have to be the same it's okay yeah
you're Ed edgier I hate that we're but
edgier then maybe someone else who might
be mainstream conservative that's okay
I don't have to share the same opinions
is every other conservative but we do
need to band together and understand the
size of the enemy that we're facing
right now and the SPLC is a huge one
especially when you see how deep their
tentacles reach into places like YouTube
and potentially Twitter so defend Gavin
calm hey Gavin looking forward to seeing
you here next week brother raca on buddy
let's have fun
the other parodies of themselves and you
know what I think that the right is
ultimately just fan girls and boys on
the left and they're curious about
progressive because they know we've got
better ideas awarded best news and
cultural Channel 2017 real tough real
turns become a TYT member today to watch
all exclusive content go to tea
y-t-dot-com
to support real progress
[Music]
[Music]
I know that one me a hodge twin sank
like a stone but my hair still dry I
think they're actually in the green room
right now they went to go have a time
what they called last time a white guy
beer like it was Fat Tire how are your
shoes I'm feeling that my kid sister fat
tire she's five and a half percent beer
I don't they feel it more because that
well actually would feel it less because
they're so lean typically if you're
Olivia more muscle mass you feel beer
less but in origins the African people
do black people that process I don't
know I'm just racist I don't it
[Music]
speaking of which not that we are but of
course we released some prank calls this
week and by the way next week I think
there is no show Monday because we're
working on a hidden-camera video here
that could be the biggest thing they'd
ever done or it could be a total bust
you never know that's kind of what
happened with an tyfa so forgive us if
we're not around monday with a show but
we did prank calls this monday and of
course there was a man who we spoke with
a lot of people are asking a lot of you
thought we faked it there's no parody of
a black person of a racist caricature
our good friend otis it is not at all as
a matter of fact otis called us back and
left a voicemail i think you have it
this is no to the voicemail from Otis
are you ready yep here we go I'm ready
hey listen um you bigots you racist
I got a touch with the police I have
this number no you didn't somebody would
be contacting you call my restaurant
again and don't hide behind a phone call
come and see me cold steel and hot lead
I think he mixed I'm sure technically
you can say hot steel bigots he should
have called the cops and then threatened
to kill us Otis you're getting us all
wrong man we want what's best for you
the blood business people
so hopefully there's a little more Otis
and if you notice if you're out there we
would love to speak with you you can be
a guest on the show this year I don't
know how we got our number and how
you've been getting lately don't ever
get this this tinnitus in there I just
recently have a sleeping disorder so
that's nice so this is the clothing that
they usually don't we start off the
thirty-seventh usually goes into
somebody's gonna get to the moving and
inspirational part um obviously if
you're a mug club member and you watch
the the full life advice segments you
kind of already know this but maybe some
of you don't first off I wanna let you
know I'm so grateful the overwhelming
support that I've received from everyone
particularly it relates to when I took a
break for the first time in years and
was kind of placing an emphasis on my
health for a while and it just kind of
came back up recently because I'm like I
said I'm about 60% there I had a couple
people recognized me in one morning if I
have a shout out to Mac shoutout to
Katrina black fan yeah Jenni we have a
lot of black fans we do and then there
was a guy this was at a gas station
where I was just getting getting a
coffee and he said hey hey hey Steven
I'm a fan I hope you feel better soon
and he shook my hand and the thing is
you know I've talked about this and it's
a lot of people make it out to be bigger
than it is but it is exhausting in
fibromyalgia and I have a wrist injury
funny enough from that rocky comeback
video that we did a while back if he
goes hitting the bag without any wraps
because going to use these classic
boxing gloves and I sprained my wrist
it's been about five weeks it really
hurts and when he shook my hand saying I
hope you feel better it hurts so bad
like nothing hurts my hand more than
either like lifting a milk jug or
someone shaking your hand and he was
very nice about it which is just kind of
brought up some emotions from before the
break I was I'm very grateful for the
support because I'll tell you this I was
I was terrified I was terrified before
we took that break that I'd lose a lot
of you that you'd be angry that you'd
think I was lazy or or scared or this
constant fear that people always have I
think we all have this fear that were
we're not enough so to see support and
to get the emails and comments and even
people who were uploading videos telling
me I even praying and how you be waiting
it's it's it's it's not something that a
lot of people get to experience but
sometimes all this it it scares me too
and I'd be doing you all of this service
if I
weren't honest about everything that's
kind of you know that's been happening
with myself because I feel as though if
you've let me into your life and I'm
very grateful for that
and sometimes I need to clarify some of
these communications and I I get a lot
of emails and if you read these life
advice you see the life advice shows
where we read emails this is something
that someone else said at this gas
station I asked if I could talk about it
but they didn't want me to use their
name so I'm trying that whenever that
happens I try to tiptoe around it said
that oh my son watches you and I really
use you as a role model and I know that
why not me saying that is like a trump
humble brightly they said the best the
reason I bring it up is actually it's
because I'm not I want to make something
really clear and we get a lot of these a
in the life advice emails like just
because we're offering advice me Gerald
people who are here I am NOT a role
model I have never wanted to be a role
model I've never claimed to be one and
I'm certainly not a good one I want to
make sure that is as clear as I can be
but I am something else I'm an example
in the difference I think is an
important one and I think it's an
important one for everyone to learn
because one of those things is authentic
and one of those is a construct a role
model is a construct often of it could
be from the media advertising or some
glorified self aggrandizement sometimes
the construct by you of someone or
something that you may think you want to
emulate or you think that you want to be
an example on the other hand is
something that everyone can be and
something everyone should be a role
model is an ideal that no one can live
up to an example of something or someone
tangible that all of us can use to
improve ourselves so see you can hold
yourself up as an example for someone in
order to help them optimize their life
without portraying yours is something to
emulate or certainly without portraying
yours as perfection that's what I think
really bothers me about this recently
I've been the example of a cautionary
tale of what not to do as it relates to
values priorities actions I let my
health fall by the wayside
I walked too close to the edge I was
stupid I push too hard I live too fast
that's not something you want to model
ourselves after okay but it is an
example you can use and that's a role
I've learned to embrace and it's one
that I think all of us not only can be
it's it's something that all of us are
something we're all burdened with for
better or worse whether you like it or
not we are all an example to everyone
around us to in some capacity to someone
around us in a very important capacity
our words our decisions our actions you
may not know it but someone right now is
looking to you as an example I guarantee
it and if you or I do myself a
disservice of setting out to be a role
model that's why I get really
uncomfortable when someone says that or
we get these emails if we set out to
even attempt to achieve becoming a role
model we've run the risk of assuming
that we can do no wrong of assuming the
moral high ground to ourselves without
verifying carrying the mantle of role
model breeds carelessness and I think
that's why it's a term I hate so much
but if you think of yourself as an
example it breeds thoughtfulness are you
in the right are you standing on the
moral high ground are you making the
right decisions it's why the whole DNC
particularly mean I'm in Santa Maria
Pinta Cortez I know I misspoke so look
your example of how to speak poorly you
dumbass
yeah it wasn't Nina Pinta santa maria
cortez that's why she aggravates me so
much she says she's the one we bogged
down recently we played this clip she
doesn't want to be bogged down with the
technicalities and fats these were her
words but more so wants to focus on
doing the moral thing that's someone who
thinks of themselves as a role model
that's someone who's already branded
themselves with that mark otherwise how
how do you know what the moral thing is
well guess what it starts with facts it
starts with the technicalities over
which Nina Pinta Santa Maria so
gleefully wants to gloss it starts and
it ends with truth now someone who
understands that they are an example as
opposed to a role model they require of
themselves facts the technical the ugly
the mundane they get bogged down in
boredom and the daily slog why because
they know that their potential example
and they hope to get it right
they want to get it right
don't assume that they have it right the
only way to get it right it comes down
to what we talk about every day on the
show it comes down to truth so everyone
watching everyone listening right now
understand and think about who this
might be that to someone in your life I
don't know who it is could be lots of
people think about them think about the
people to whom you are a potential
example because we are all examples
period you're not a role model you'll
never be a role model there is no one on
this earth right now who is a role model
but what kind of example are you going
to be someone who gets it right someone
who at least tries someone who seeks
truth
or you can assume yourself to moral high
ground and being a role are you just
going to be another cautionary tale
decision I think we all have to make
this important
[Music]